bonjour et merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
alors quel regard portez-vous sur
l'attitude de paris dans ce dossier mais
grattoir qui l'oppose au royaume uni
paris et dans la matière comme souvent
d'ailleurs adepte du double langage on
voit bien monsieur darmanin s'agiter en
conférence de presse sur les plateaux de
télévision et dire qu'il va contrôler
l'immigration qu'il va arrêter le
communautarisme que le droit d'être en
france n'autorise pas à tous les excès
et dans le même temps la france ne fait
rien pour contrôler les flux migratoires
en tant que pays européens déjà il n'y a
aucune influence l'union européenne est
une passoire
vous avez parlé de l'italie 150 %
d'augmentation je rappelle qu'à l'époque
où notre allié matteo salvini était
ministre de l'intérieur il y avait eu
une chute de 80% de l'arrivée de
migrants mais vous le savent il n'y a
pas de frontière entre l'italie et la
france donc bien évidemment demain la
plupart de ces migrants se retrouveront
en france pourquoi bien tout simplement
parce que nous avons un des régimes les
plus généreux en terme d' aides sociales
1 milliard par an pour la santé gratuite
pour les migrants 2 milliards par an
pour les mineurs isolés
le logement les coûts d'infrastructure
qui coûte 6 milliards et demi par an
bref la france est un eldorado pour
migrants et aucune des mesures
importantes de contrôle des frontières
de renvoi chez eux des migrants illégaux
et d'arrêt des aides sociales n'a été
prise pour se gouverner par ce
gouvernement
alors pour revenir sur ce dossier entre
la france et le royaume uni les les
britanniques semblent manifestement un
peu à cran sur le sujet en déguster a
même proposé de récupérer la ville de
calais pour en finir avec les migrants
est ce que ça vous inspire quel
commentaire
cette proposition du député est un petit
peu farfelue mais ça ne doit pas cacher
derrière la démarche légitime du royaume
uni quai de protéger ses frontières et
protéger sa population ce qui est plus
délicat c'est la situation de la france
qui se retrouve dans une situation
extrêmement paradoxale elle doit d'un
côté empêcher les migrants de partir
ceux qui sont à calais alors qu'elle
devrait utiliser toute son énergie à
empêcher les migrants d'entrer ceux qui
vont arriver par l'espagne et l'italie
on voit bien à quel point ces accords de
schengen sont ubuesques
ils sont faits pour autoriser l'arrivée
de migrants et la france est totalement
impuissante
alors on a beau jeu de se gausser des
anglais mais on pourrait remarquer quand
même que c'est au moins un pays qui a
décidé de contrôler ses frontières et de
décider qui vient ou qui ne vient pas
sur son territoire
alors concernant l'italie le pays a
accueilli cette année plus de 21000 600
migrants est ce qu'on peut vraiment
parler d'une vague comparé à l'année
2016 2017 lorsque le pays avait
accueilli plus de 180 3000 migrants
écoutez d'abord nous ne sommes qu'au
milieu de l'année donc tout reste encore
possible ce qui est inquiétant c'est
l'accélération du phénomène et puis
c'est aussi l'origine des migrants
puisque la plupart des migrants à peu
près la moitié de ceux qui arrivent en
italie sont des tunisiens c'est à dire
que ce ne sont pas des gens qui fuient
la guerre ce ne sont pas des gens qui
sont persécutés on a l'a clairement une
immigration économique un détournement
du droit d'asile qui s'annonce c'est en
cela que cet inquiétant c'est surtout
inquiétant pour la france quand on voit
que tous les chiffres sont au rouge
en six ans le nombre de demandeurs
d'asile a doublé sur le territoire
national et nous avons pour la première
fois l'année dernière atteint le chiffre
de 450 3000 migrants légaux entre ceux
qui ont obtenu des autorisations
d'arriver sur ce territoire et ceux qui
demandent le droit d'asile dont vous le
voyez la france a baissé les bras à la
france accueille toute la misère du
monde
et comme l'italie elle même ne tient
plus ses frontières contrairement à
l'époque salvini et bien cela met en
danger nos équilibres financiers nous
équilibres sociaux en france mais aussi
notre sécurité et notre identité
regardez l'italie et les côtes
britanniques sont principalement touché
la france très peu en comparaison
très peu en direct mais vous savez très
bien que quand on met le pied à malte en
grèce ou en italie à partir du moment où
on est allé sur le sol de l'union
européenne
il y à la libre circulation alors cette
libre circulation qui laisse aujourd'hui
arriver des gens porteurs du coc vie de
19 en france
eh bien elle et sera demain des migrants
arrivés aussi c'est d'ailleurs par là
que passe l'essentiel des migrants qui
demandent le droit d'asile et je dois le
dire aussi
c'est aussi par là que son passé
certains des terroristes qui ont tué des
français ne pas contrôler ses frontières
c'est mettre notre population en danger
il faut le répéter le seriner et
monsieur darmanin tant qu'il n'aura pas
compris ça il n'aura pas pris les
mesures pour contrôler les frontières et
bien travaillera à vide
merci laurent jacobellis je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole du rassemblement
national